what system it's computer-based okay
electronic um why might I have
significant difficulties providing help
in making choices when where I figure a
human decisions okay so reason number
one anyone in the team incompetent
you're gonna have to be a little more
specific with that because humans are
incompetent to write so you're gonna
have to be more specific than that I'm
gonna give you another triad and if not
then you get zero and they already win
anyone in the team there's like it's
like nine of you impaired users I get
I'm giving you 15 seconds inadequate
information now before we go on you're
gonna have to explain that a little more
what does that be okay so how's that
different to when a human doesn't have
inadequate information isn't that a
problem for a human as well okay so hold
on you don't actually mean inadequate
information you need that a computer
come on articulate it for me because
that's not what you mean
you're saying something different you
guys what's what's your reason this is
not your reason because you're saying he
will isn't gonna have this problem in
some situations can you articulate what
your actual reason is yeah
okay all right so he's our reason okay
so you guys have to pay attention so you
don't overlap right the idea is that a
computer can only take information
that's presented to it directly is that
what you mean right
whereas a human can look at a situation
and then if actually did you think
anything through it okay so it's
actually a logic right all right so
there there's our there's our first
reason okay I'm turning over the team
and what's your first reason say again
low accountability now you're gonna have
to explain that we're gonna have to
explain that what does that mean maybe
you should tell me what accountability
is and then what why low accountability
okay so if it's a computer right and
they make a bad decision well they make
good decisions like how do you blame
them or you know praise or whatever okay
it's not a human all right okay I'll pay